J'avais tout commencé pour créer un impact positif
dans la vie des artisans.
Et je sentais que j'avais fait le contraire.
Je me sentais tellement coupable
que j'ai décidé de cacher cet échec
de mes conversations et de mon CV pendant des années.
Je ne connaissais pas d'autres entrepreneurs qui ont échoué,
et je pensais être la seule loser au monde.
Une nuit, sept ans après, je sortais avec des amis
et nous parlions de la vie d'entrepreneur.
Et bien sûr, le problème de l'échec fut abordé.
J'ai décidé d'avouer à mes amis l'histoire de ma société ratée.
Et ils ont partagé des histoires similaires.
A ce moment, une pensée est devenue très claire dans mon esprit :
tous mes amis étaient des ratés.
(Rires)
Plus sérieusement, j'ai réalisé ce soir-là
que de une : je n'étais pas la seule loser au monde,
et que de deux : nous avons tous un échec secret.
Dites-moi si ce n'est pas vrai.
Cette nuit fut pour moi un exorcisme.
J'ai réalisé que partager ses échecs rend plus fort, et non plus faible.
Et être ouverte à ma vulnérabilité
m'a aidée à me joindre aux autres de manière plus profonde et significative
pour adopter des leçons de vie que je n'aurais jamais apprises auparavant.
En conséquence de cette expérience
de partage d'histoires d'entreprises qui ont échoué,
nous avons créé une plateforme d’événements
pour aider les autres à partager les histoires de leurs échecs.
Nous l'avons appelée : « Fuckup Nights ».
Des années après, nous avons également créé un centre de recherche
dédié à l'histoire de l'échec
et son implication sur les affaires, les gens et la société
et comme on aime les noms cool, on l'a nommé « l'Institut de l'Échec. »
C'était surprenant de voir que quand un entrepreneur monte sur scène
et partage une histoire d'échec,
il peut apprécier cette expérience.
Ce n'est pas forcément un moment de honte et d'embarras,
comme ça l'était dans le passé.
C'est une opportunité de partager des leçons apprises
et de construire de l'empathie.
Nous avons également découvert
que le partage d'échecs entre des membres d'une équipe produit un effet magique.
Les liens se forgent plus solidement et la collaboration devient plus facile.
Nos événements et nos projets de recherche
nous ont permis de découvrir quelques faits intéressants.
Par exemple, les hommes et les femmes réagissent d'une manière différente
après l'échec d'une entreprise.
La réaction la plus commune parmi les hommes
est de commencer une nouvelle affaire dans l'année qui suit l'échec,
mais dans un secteur différent,
alors que les femmes décident de chercher un travail
et de reporter la création d'une nouvelle entreprise.
Notre hypothèse sur la raison de ceci
est que les femmes tendent à souffrir davantage du syndrome de l'imposteur.
Nous pensons qu'il nous manque quelque chose pour être un bon entrepreneur.
Mais j'ai vu dans de nombreux cas que les femmes ont tout ce qu'il faut.
Nous avons juste besoin de faire le premier pas.
Dans le cas des hommes,
il est plus commun de voir qu'ils sentent qu'ils ont suffisamment de savoir
et qu'ils doivent le mettre en pratique autre part avec plus de chance.
Une autre découverte intéressante est celle-ci :
les entrepreneurs du monde entier ne gèrent pas l'échec de la même façon.
Par exemple, la réaction la plus commune
après l'échec d'une entreprise sur le continent américain
est de retourner à l'école.
Alors qu'en Europe, la réaction habituelle est de chercher un thérapeute.
(Rires)
Nous ne savons pas laquelle de ces réactions est la meilleure après un échec,
mais c'est quelque chose que nous allons creuser à l'avenir.
Une autre fait intéressant mis au jour est
le profond impact de la politique publique sur les entrepreneurs en faillite.
Par exemple, dans mon pays, au Mexique,
le cadre réglementaire est tellement ardu
que fermer une affaire peut coûter beaucoup de temps et d'argent.
Commençons par l'argent.
Dans le meilleur des scénarios,
où il n'y a pas de problème avec les partenaires,
les fournisseurs, les clients, les employés,
dans le meilleur scénario possible,
fermer une entreprise officiellement coûte 2 000 dollars.
Ce qui est une somme énorme au Mexique.
Quelqu'un qui gagne le salaire minimum
devrait travailler pendant 15 mois pour économiser cette somme.
Maintenant, parlons du temps.
Comme vous le savez peut-être, dans la plupart du monde développé,
l'espérance de vie moyenne d'un commerce est de deux ans.
Au Mexique, le processus de fermeture officielle d'un commerce dure deux ans.
Qu'arrive-t-il lorsque l'espérance de vie moyenne d'une entreprise
est similaire au temps qu'il faut pour la fermer si elle n'est pas rentable ?
Bien sûr, cela décourage la création d'entreprise
et promeut l'économie informelle.
De fait, les recherches économétriques montrent
que si déclarer faillite coûtait moins de temps et d'argent,
plus de nouvelles entreprises seraient créées.
Pour cette raison, en 2017,
nous avons proposé une série de recommandations de politique publique
pour la procédure officielle de fermeture d'une entreprise au Mexique.
Pendant une année entière,
nous avons travaillé avec des entrepreneurs de tout le pays
et avec le Congrès.
La bonne nouvelle est que nous avons réussi à aider à changer la loi.
Yes !
(Applaudissements)
L'idée est que quand la nouvelle réglementation entre en vigueur,
les entrepreneurs pourront fermer leur entreprise par une procédure en ligne
qui est plus rapide et gratuite.
(Soupir)
Cette nuit où nous avons inventé Fuckup Nights,
nous n'aurions jamais imaginé que le mouvement prendrait autant d'ampleur.
Nous sommes actifs dans 80 pays, désormais.
A ce moment-là, notre seule intention
était de mettre le sujet de l'échec à l'agenda.
Pour aider nos amis à voir que l'échec est un sujet dont on doit discuter.
Ce n'est pas une source d'humiliation, comme ça l'a été dans le passé,
ou une raison de célébration, comme certains l'affirment.
En fait, je vais vous avouer une chose.
A chaque fois que j'entends des types ou des étudiants de la Silicon Valley
se vanter d'échouer rapidement et souvent comme si c'était trivial, je grimace.
Car je pense qu'il y a un mauvais côté au mantra « échouez rapidement ».
Échouer rapidement est une bonne façon d'accélérer l'apprentissage
et d'éviter de gaspiller du temps.
Mais je crains que quand on présente aux entrepreneurs
l'échec rapide comme la seule et unique solution,
on ne prépare en réalité le lit de la fainéantise.
Il se pourrait que l'on promeuve l'abandon facile.
Je crains aussi que la culture de l'échec rapide
puisse minimiser les conséquences dévastatrices
de la faillite d'une entreprise.
Par exemple, quand mon entreprise sociale a péri,
la pire chose était que je devais aller rencontrer la communauté indigène
et annoncer à ces femmes que l'entreprise avait échoué
et que c'était de ma faute.
Certains pourraient voir cela comme une bonne opportunité d'apprendre,
mais la vérité est que la fermeture de mon entreprise
représentait bien plus que ça.
Cela signifiait que les femmes cesseraient de recevoir le salaire
dont elles avaient tant besoin.
Pour cette raison, je veux proposer quelque chose.
Je veux proposer que, de la même manière que l'on a dépassé le principe
d'humilier publiquement les entrepreneurs en faillite,
nous devons remiser l'idée qu'échouer vite est toujours la meilleure solution.
Je souhaite aussi proposer un nouveau mantra :
échouez intelligemment.
Nous devons nous souvenir que les entreprises sont faites de personnes,
qu'elles ne sont pas des entités qui apparaissent et disparaissent
magiquement et sans conséquence.
Quand une entreprise meurt, des gens perdent leur emploi.
D'autres perdent leur argent.
Et dans le cas des entreprises sociales ou vertes,
la fin de cette activité peut engendrer un impact négatif
sur les écosystèmes ou les communautés qu'elles essayaient de protéger.
Mais que signifie « échouer intelligemment » ?
Cela signifie qu'il faut être conscient de l'impact, des conséquences
de la faillite de l'entreprise.
Être conscient des leçons apprises.
Et être conscient de la responsabilité
de partager ces leçons avec le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)